you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hi Ryan hi how are you
I'm fine how are you I'm good good job
good week did good I mean this could go
on all right and unsubscribe first I
want to say that as you know in love
with Michael Rose McChrystal but it's no
longer we let it go I thank you for any
of you who listen to it and supported it
there were reasons Chris Sullivan's wife
is pregnant it's a far drive for him and
there were many listeners and bunch of
other stuff but I had a good time doing
it I really enjoyed it and I hope you
guys enjoyed it so it's one of those
things where you know if it doesn't
quite work out you move on and you you
learn from it but I'm still doing this
podcast inside of you because I love it
and I love you guys and I appreciate you
know I just went to Portland Ryan mm-hmm
so how was it it was great you know I do
the cons and people come up to me it's
probably more than ever now they just
you know they have their stories and
people like they join patreon by the way
thank you for joining patreon and
becoming my patrons and I and I think
we're doing a great job Bryce and I are
doing a great job of giving you guys
extra footage and you know more always
responding to you as much as I can and
you know we do q and A's and just
there's so much stuff we're throwing out
there and I hope it's worth your while
and you're having fun if you have any
ideas keeping to yourself not kidding
I'm kidding but I hope you're enjoying
it I really really truly appreciate the
support there on patreon
but the podcast when I go to cons people
are just like you know people if it
affects their lives it's cool you know
and so sometimes I'm thinking I'm
getting too serious and then these
interviews and then I'm like but I like
talking about serious stuff I like
talking about stuff that sometimes
people are uncomfortable talking about
so I'm gonna keep doing it and if you
get bored then hopefully you won't stop
subscribing but I don't think they're
boring the fun yeah they're really
interesting yeah you learn a lot I'm
learning I'm I think other people who
are learning yeah it's not the whole
point of it you learn and it's not just
your typical freaking interview it's uh
I mean blue by the way I'm a constant
work in progress I mean I have I was
having anxiety this last weekend I
breathed through it I
try to meditate I just acknowledged it
like hey this is happening it's not
gonna kill me I'm healthy I'm not having
a heart attack you're doing okay kid I
just said kid because I'm looking at the
Karate Kid poster across from me but so
again thank you for listening subscribe
tell your friends to subscribe I'll be
in Richmond for a con look it up
probably my Twitter Instagram soon I'm
also gonna be in Mexico in March and
there's more coming this summer we do
small though nights with Tom if you
haven't seen it you need to come see it
because you're gonna really enjoy it we
do about an hour and a half of improv
and read scenes and people really seem
to respond what else
Katherine McNamara episode was great
last week yeah that was really great and
she's sweet to talk to if she's uh she's
a busy girl she loves to work she is
busy and she's really there's not a lot
of negative things in her life so it was
kind of like you know you're trying to
get something like hey come on did you
stub your toe today what did you do but
she's uh she's full of I think that's
just as important as hearing people who
you know tell you about their problems
and things like that it's just as
important to hear the good things that
are on life and how to appreciate them
and I think that's what she does
so I think that's so that's important
our transition of video is getting
closer and closer so remember it's a
learning curve so when you see it please
share it with everybody subscribe to the
YouTube inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum Ryan here is the is doing his
best
be nice teach them together he's he's
learning although he does this for a
living I do know how to do this son of a
[ __ ] it should be great yeah it will be
and also if you want any inside of you
merch or left on Laurel merch from the
band it's all on the inside of you store
so if you got it inside of you store
calm or whatever you'll see it's on my
link or whatever and the music is free
on Spotify and everywhere else so thank
you so much for everything today's
episode you know I was gonna wait to air
this because you'll hear about this in
the podcast but Dominic Monaghan and
Billy Boyd from Lord of the Rings are
here today it's just really fun to watch
them sort of bounce off each other
because Billy is more of the
you know he's a shy guy a little bit you
know he's a family guy he's is very
bright and not the Dom isn't times
obviously bright much brighter than me
but watching them their friendship you
could see they've been friends for a
long time and how they became friends
and how it sort of evolved and all the
great stories one of my favorite stories
was the the fight the fist fight that
Dominic Monaghan and our land of bloom
almost got into did you like that yeah
of course that was a mobile rings it was
great to like sit there and listen to
all the stories yeah just just hanging
out yeah for years for years they not
talk about their tattoos when they got
tattoos it there's so many great stories
in here and there's a I'm not gonna even
give it away now but there's something
you'll want to hear when you listen to
it something they're doing they're
working on together you'll have to
listen to the podcast and I think you'll
get a real kick out of it I'm looking
really forward to this but they're two
exceptional guys I loved having him here
in my house and they recorded something
at my house they used my engineer Ryan
mm-hmm I'm not gonna say what it was but
maybe if you listen you'll understand
and I think you're gonna have fun with
this
let's get inside Dominic Monaghan and
Billy Boyd it's my view you're listening
to inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
this feels because I've done this before
that's this is this is how it starts now
you won't hear a [ __ ] once for me is
that what happens Oh Dom yeah Dom said
that dump says you know you're a
gentleman you're you you're a little
quiet you're really funny when you're
with him only with me
he makes me funny I don't know if that's
true but I do look at the both here
right now and I know that you guys are
really best friends you're the really
close friends right that's not a lie no
that's not bond
I don't know you can but so do you think
the the saying opposites attract is true
do you think that like with women or men
whatever it is friends that were
attracted to I mean you're attracted to
him not sexually maybe definitely with
magnets
that's science yeah but with people I
would say no I think mainly you're
attracted to people who like to do the
things that you late to do what is it
you like to do Billy I like to sleep I
like to drink coffee I like to do very
little to be honor see I'm I feel like
I'm the opposite because I'm not big on
those things I'm not that big on
sleeping I'll have the occasional coffee
to wake me up and what was the last
thing that he said mainly doing nothing
yeah I do a bunch of stuff okay he likes
to do stuff
do you follow his Instagram yeah he's
always you know from wild things ever
he's all over the world he's yeah he's
always doing something he's interesting
and he's do you find that though Don
that you keep busy just because if you
stop you're gonna voices come the voices
come in because I know that's with me
with me you know I I have things going
on in my life and you know if I stop for
a second I started really obsess yeah
and mines more I mean I'm sure there's
something to be said for that mines as
I've got older as we all get older
hopefully you start to realize the
things that work for you and the things
that don't and you tend to lean away
from the bad things and go towards the
good things and if I'm just doing
something that's ticking me along like
I've been doing miniature Japanese kind
of Lego bricks
for the past cannon I don't know what
that it was so it's basically Lego but
very slim down so the pieces can be a
millimeter you need to put them on oh I
couldn't do it I don't have the patience
yes you have the patience for that
because in the end the vision don't you
have to have really good eyesight
probably do you have slide because my
eyes are really bad but with you specs
on would you be alright well these are
strong and I still have problems with
things okay like for instance looking at
my penis yeah I still get you magnified
guns no but so these are tiny version of
Legos time now what you could think
Billy would be interested in this tiny
Lego game I think Billy would but maybe
not in the way that I am because this is
Billy and I have lived together on
occasion over the years and the thing we
live together really well but one of the
things that seems to would eventually
get under Billy's skin is when I'm doing
the miniature Legos I'm listening to a
podcast and I've got a movie on in the
other room and Billy when he used to
live to me he'd be like what room you in
I'd be like I'm in this room he's like
why is there a movie on in that room why
is the radio on in the kitchen why is
this going on I like that difference
wait a minute so for you to focus a lot
of things have to go on at the same many
things happen that's awful you can't do
that Billy no it's a nightmare there's a
movie on and music on and he's not in
those rooms so and he'll commend to them
and then put something else on it's just
as awful it's like hell yeah it sounds
kind of like hell but you know I kind of
get it being someone with a Dede I tend
to fall asleep when the TV's on and
there's rain going on but but I'm weird
I can't fall asleep when there's people
in the house I feel like they're gonna
destroy my house they're gonna do
something to me while I sleep I always
think these horrible things or even
finally like old friends I have trouble
sleeping I'm very paranoid I think that
you know it's like somebody's gonna come
in the room and try to mess with me now
like hurt me physically but you know I
don't get that soul I know it's well you
could fall asleep anywhere yeah if I'm
horizontal like I've fallen asleep and
in in airports no problem if I can get
flat and there's a lot of stuff going on
around me I think I happened because
when I was a kid my brother had quite
bad at asthma so they'd be doctors and
my mom who's a nurse in the room and my
brother in quite a bad physical shape
and my mum would always be mystified by
the fact that I would just sleep all the
way
no problem so it doesn't doesn't bother
me apparently any sort of repetition
helps you sleep even if it's really load
so like someone banging a drum f its
repetitive is easier to sleep and then
silence if it's what repetitive
repetitive if it's so cool like I that's
why like an engine makes you follow
through just that yeah
but anything that kind of is
inconsistent you have to be honest and
to do with like Jesus good now
dawn is it safe to say that like you
know people could say oh you know he's a
ladies man he look at all these
beautiful women he's gone out with and
this and there's not many I'm not seeing
that they say many yeah man think
obviously I've been lucky enough to have
some some attractive girlfriends over
the years but you've had a relationship
long relationship yeah but a lot of them
have not been online Billy knows more
about ladies that I've been with and my
know more about ladies that Billy's with
before he was married because he's been
married since what Oh something I have
been remarried since 2010 2010 you've
been married so almost 10 years yeah man
but I was worth Allison for you know 10
years before that
well you had a child with her right yeah
yeah look jack cousin Jack have a middle
name William Jack William Boyd JW boy
there has always been a William Boyd in
Scotland senses his beginnings that's
real
William boys now I'm thinking you
weren't the type of guy look at you
you're a good-looking guy yeah I'm
pretty good-looking yeah yeah
you are you're musician yeah an actor
and I'm thinking okay is MIDI but he's
not like you never go out and party and
pick up women were you ever like that is
he doesn't look like you I knew Billy
when he was single in Scotland that's
before he got married and he he would
give most of the people on the film
career run for their money because he's
got that wonderful charm
Scottish accent charm he's funny and I
think we'd billionaire the same because
we're not six foot two because you know
we're hobbits was slightly small instead
[ __ ] how tall are you I'm five seven
I'll tell you five eight
Billy always says he really always says
he's five seven when he's with me on
line five seven five seven but I think
that becomes very non-threatening for a
lady they think wow look ladies nice
League threatening but we can be so okay
do you think you have like a dislike for
adversity towards people who are tall
mean no I love told people because some
people have what they call a small man
complex but that's probably much
Napoleon component complex yeah yeah no
I don't think you have that I never
really noticed I was small you know I
was at school and it would be around and
your grade system sort of seventh grade
something like that and and it was in a
science class and they measured everyone
and we'd everyone to do this sort of
percentile thing you know and I was in
like the bottom like two percent of
height and until that moment I thought I
was like normal or slightly talk I
already told that moment I had no I
people always said to me I remember like
relative seeing oh look at belly he's
going to be tall like his dad because my
dad was like sex for which and Scotland
I suppose is Preto hmm so in my head
always thought I was told you know until
I was like 12 or 13 or some and then
everybody kind of passing you by well I
don't even know if I was ever tall but
until they measured us in science class
I just always thought I was told it was
just that's what they do in science
class they measure you they measure you
anyway did you weigh as a 12 year old
500 pounds I was slightly stoked yeah
and you that didn't even bother you
either did it I didn't know I was gonna
hide younger team you were boy were you
I could only get three or four inches
these are lies well that part was a lie
but the hate thing wasn't a lie I
honestly thought I was med too
why do you think you had that confidence
done was it your upbringing was it your
grandma telling you you could do
anything you're tall I think it was
relative seeing to me he's going to be
told like his father and I just thought
yeah I'll be told like my father my mom
was only five feet tall
when did you realize [ __ ] I'm not
growing anymore this is it I was our own
then I think that put a fool stop on my
growth but I made you a hobbit you know
you wouldn't be a hobbit you can ever
grew one more wrench I wouldn't have
been a hub is that true yeah yeah
because we all have to be the same
matching hi why can't you wear a shoe
that's a little higher yeah they just
wouldn't done that I don't think but
let's say Elijah who was obviously you
know that the the most important Hobbit
in that entire trilogy right was
six-foot they would probably have cast
three or the six-foot guys but I think
Elijah's five five he's around about our
high so then they had two matches all
together I'm same as bill I went through
school thinking fine and it doesn't
bother me at all I knew I was probably a
little bit smaller than most people but
let me be more cheeky it let me get away
with more stuff that's true isn't it cuz
I was listening this you're not gonna
believe this
I was a smallest kid in my high school
really I was a smallest kid my high
school I sold well hey I'm six feet on
the dot now but I didn't grow from my
senior I was five foot four I graduated
at five four and then I quit eight
inches in the next two years I think
that's why I have a lot of back issues
yeah yeah like what age is that the
seniors so when you graduate you're like
I was 17 and I was in 12th grade so I
graduated and it wasn't till after that
summer after I graduated high school
that I started to grow into college and
people from my high school would come up
to me a year later or two years later
and go are you Michael Rosenbaum
I'm like yeah and they're like what
happened do you hear in your Paul's now
wait I know they didn't ask me that but
you know I get a lot more attention from
girls yeah yeah I was I was always oh
look he's a little rosey yeah you're
right I remember feeling like I remember
crying actually in front of my parents
cuz my dad six-four six-five my mom's
tall for a woman and my mom was always
doing popping valium and drugs you know
that growing up in my my dad was a
pothead and he was you know doing drugs
in the 60s or whatever before I was born
he stopped but you know I always said
what what drugs were you on this is your
fault why am I so small and I remember
storming out of the room and crying
because it's like you did this [ __ ]
drug and do sperm that's what I thought
happens it's good to blame people for
things yeah I like to blame people do
people you're being sarcastic yeah
someone told me once that male children
are always taller than their mother now
people who are guys I let's say that
word again
Mele you didn't say it like that meal
meal meal meal meal children are always
taller than their mothers and I've
looked at that sense and I was told this
years ago and it's always been true yeah
that really with me you're taller than
your mom yeah mom was tiny and you were
taller than your mom yeah how tall was
your mom five foot one what about your
grandma five foot four well and my
father said what the one your grandma
who raised you um well
oh she was tall but as she got older she
got smaller that's what happens is that
is that like a collapsing of the Debray
I think it's that's what happens you
start to hunched over
you're a spine sort of everything the
bones start to get I don't know am I
making this [ __ ] no no only as old as
your Spain so always what you think that
is a truth yes only as old as you said
I'm gonna snow as your finger younger
than you some your Spain someone said
that someone very wise do you guys get
really sad when this happens to me when
I'm driving in LA a lot in traffic and
you see someone walking on the street
very very encumbered by spinal issues
like walking but poorly bent over with
sticks and those walker things you know
you're dark and you're talking to
someone who has had seven spine
surgeries do you have you done the stick
thing do you've yet to walk with sticks
that a leg issue hmm no do I want you
mean crutches no no crutches you know
walking blocks with all the walls are
the walking sticks no I've never used a
stick I mean thank God but I think it's
from hockey and all the [ __ ]
I had I just had my c4 c5 spot us fused
in my neck so I to next surgeries and
had infused on my on my back for thought
of sports and [ __ ] but what is it
because when you're playing hockey
hockey hockey puck Runyan you know
that's a rarity ok that's a rarity those
checks you know when people hit you into
the boards and hockey but it's also wear
and tear it's also working at a grocery
store I hate to admit this but probably
a lot of it stems from working in a
grocery store you know you throw boxes
off the truck
oh well out of the stock boy I probably
making 335 an hour I probably hurt my
disk then you know what it's sexier to
say that you got it in hockey game much
sexier when you've been shot so I always
do when one goes oh my god you've had
surgeries well how I got a hockey least
a hockey field do you know what check do
you know what checking is let me buy you
a martini and I'll tell you what
checking is when they check you really
hard you know I wouldn't like to start
the game and someone thinks right the
first tackle I came here when they
checked you really hard after that can
you skate over to me to say key not chat
me quite as hard anymore cause you've
already done a really big no I don't
think that's a pro you do you saw your
gloves off and you go at it that's a
possibility that you're allowed to do
that what do you guys think cuz you're
from Scotland you're from Germany no
England right but flame Jim I claim a
nice Hitler reference and we got that in
there it really disappoints me is he
retired I mean apart from the war in the
genocide with the fire he retired the
name Adolph Denis you can't call your
kid a Dolf now which i think is a
wonderful name come on addy addy come on
get in the car but name him addy
yeah you don't want Adolf it's just you
know it just it you know like oh there's
my other son Mussolini yeah Mussolini
over here will you Benito Mussolini but
if I just said Benito you would enough
what about the last name bringing up
Hitler has that disappeared what Hitler
is that people still called mr. Herr
well I think supposedly the Hitler
family when all that you know kind of
frack our occur
in Europe right they said we got change
our name now so there are Hitler's still
around people who come from a previous
print lers yeah but they're not your
print list but they're not calling
themself Hitler and have you changed it
to one thing like of the old one thing
now sure eyes are all just they're
almost Cellini's now yes that's it there
I'm not sure about that all right wait
wait let me just tell Stan Hitler supply
please support supposedly the guys so
there's a there's a pair of brothers who
made sneakers this needs to be a movie I
heard it's true but I'm not sure if at
history might be an urban myth but it's
true should totally be a movie right it
was a pair of brothers who made shoes
and they got into a big fight over an
artistic idea behind the shoe and one
brother said okay I'm gonna leave and
I'll form my own company and the other
one said okay I'm gonna stay and I'll
see what happens with this company the
one who stayed his name is Adolph
Dassler german and he called his company
a d-des and his brother went away and
created the shoe company Puma and if not
spoke to each other or Puma as they say
in America they're not spoke to each
other since and they're in two of the
biggest shoe companies in the world it
was a fantastic story well told you
could be you could be a DDoS and I'll be
his other someone that Puma Puma Puma
Destler any I'm sorry inside of you is
brought to you by baked by Melissa
that's right
baked by Melissa I got this box Ryan and
I was like who sent me this beautiful
box it's colorful what's in the box
what's in the box the box dude beautiful
cupcakes I'm talking red velvet milk
chocolate cookies and cream I mean and
they were just like tons of them in this
little box and so tasty and so adorable
I mean it made me giggle a little bit I
was like who sent these and then
everybody's wait it's my spot
I actually naturally reacted to a gift
from my sponsor and it was easy dude
cool cupcakes are just like these little
cupcakes and I still have my put them in
the freezer cuz you know I want it I
want to I don't I don't want them to go
bad no you know them Sam
mm-hmm but look guys Valentine's Day is
here I mean it's really close
time's running out to send your
Valentine's a one-of-a-kind memorable
unexpected gift that's what this gift is
if you want to WoW your Valentine this
year
send them bite-sized cupcakes from baked
by Melissa I might want to marry Melissa
really well I don't know and she makes
amazing little adorable cupcakes that
are just tasty as heck all right I told
you about the flavors there's so many
flavors to choose from
I like the red velvet of quartz the the
dulce de leche something like dr. de
leche dos de leche that was good
see I can't pronounce it but you did
thank god you're here they got vegan
they got gluten-free options it's just I
don't know man
they're moist some people hate that word
I don't think so when you're talking
about a cupcake you want it to be moist
torcida said it twice now and it's
perfect size it's the perfect size folks
baked by melissa offers one and two-day
shipping available nationwide remember
the last day for standard shipping for
Valentine's Day delivery is February
12th at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
so you make you might want to know that
I love these things they're cute as heck
and I hope they stay my sponsor because
I'm getting really well what's the word
when someone's spoiling you
I guess spoiling you this Valentine's
Day sends your loved ones the perfect
gift baked by Melissa go to bake by
melissa comm slash iou and use promo
code IOU to get 15% off your order take
advantage of this special offer for
podcast listeners that's 15% off at bake
by melissa comm slash I owe you that's
big by melissa dot-com slash iou promo
code I owe you get some of these they're
delicious inside of you is brought to
you by CBD MD CBD MD if you know me you
knowing the king of CBD and I believe in
it I think people really react to this
stuff I know my stepdad
that's weird I call them my stepdad he's
Gordon for God's sakes he's Gordon my
mom's husband of 18 years is that my
stepdad yeah Oh Eddie fat Gordon all
right if you're listening you're my
stepdad congratulations but they sent me
a care package of all this great stuff
at CBD MD and it soothes me I need it it
distracts me from any pain that I have
personally guys were over a month into
the new year and I bet a lot of you've
already given up on your New Year's
resolutions
I know Ryan did you Haven have any New
Year's resolutions I didn't I didn't
make any this year did you it did you
think about maybe working out this year
more went for a run this morning that
feel good
that's that's that's good enough all
right just because you haven't gone back
to the gym guys since the beginning of
January it doesn't mean you have to wait
till next year to get off the couch
again
and even though getting started can be
tough with a little help from our
friends at CBD MD and their amazing
topical products which I use every day
you'll be crushing your goals in no time
they got the CBD fries with menthol I
was putting some on my buddy Tom Welling
who plays Clark Kent you know sit in
Smallville with me and he's like dude
you what are you doing what are you
doing and then within about 10 seconds
like bro that's cooling relief my
muscles my joints they just feel real
good right now he didn't say exactly
that but he liked it he's like you have
to give me some of this stuff you change
his voice and everything he did man he
was like yeah I use this constantly and
you know if I'm using it it's probably
working that's what I'm gonna say it is
working so you might want to check this
out they've got creams they've got the
little balls you know where you rub it
on the back your head you know they have
all sorts of stuff that you can get from
there they have gummies really stellar
products and I really enjoy it and I
take it with me everywhere I go CBD MD
CBD MD is offering our listeners my
listeners 25% off are you listening to
me right now 25% off your next order
when you use the promo code I owe you at
checkout
once again that's CB DMD comm promo code
IOU for 25% off your purchase of
superior CBD oil products from CBD MD
that's right CBD MD comm use the promo
code IOU for 25% off your purchase of
superior CBD oil products from CBD MD
so let's go back to this you guys became
friends you're both you didn't meet on
Lord of the Rings we did we'd answer you
met yes I mean you told the story of
course but when did you know Billy that
I liked this Dom he's my favorite of all
the others um probably quite early so
you admit that he's your favorite
I was just about to say that I'm not
gonna admit that yet because I've feel
was there were so young and a
relationship I could let him down
totally let me down Sean Astin's a nice
guy yeah he could become my favorite
he's been on your show yes he has he has
a lesson - yeah yeah it's a good store
thanks man you had to do some research
before you said yes I'll let you sexy
boys that's true yeah I think I'm a sexy
voice get good voice thanks you do you
doubt you have a great voice for this
type of medium deep because a lot of
Americans I think your age our age tend
to kind of speak a little bit more up
there I don't think that the voice in
the cocktail yeah well you know I might
thanks but anyway back to your favorites
back to your favorite Dom so be careful
here cuz I am actually gonna say you're
my favorites I just don't want you to
know that dorm arrived in New Zealand a
little later than the rest of us Sean an
Elijah and Orlando and stuff because I
think you were working on something yes
that very successful actor he was very
successful he was working yeah it was
working he was in Europe doing something
excellent
so anyway and did you have a shaved head
yeah it's a shaved head when I first met
him and I thought he looks quite sexy
thank you you know he's an attractive to
him and I remember we were in wardrobe
and they said the guy in Mary's just
arrived everybody should go up and meet
him and I went up and and he seemed he
seemed a very sort of happy it just came
off the flight I think and you gone
straight there I may be telling this
story completely wrong strand and Dom
will correct me but we sort of said
hello and and and he got measured for
wardrobe and stuff and then we went to
the pub and we had a beer and we played
pool and I said I like this guy just
like that yeah
like there's something innately kind
about him some more fun yeah because
that was that's a long flight that's
like 30 hours and he still was able and
he's like yeah let's come on let's go
out and we'll we'll get to know each
other and say hello and I like that I
thought yeah I could see the smile on
your face you have sort of like this
this feeling of like just the pure
honesty of what you just said it wasn't
like a talent story I could just see
that you do you do like each other
yeah there's something very deeply
enmeshed into the culture of being
British of which billionaire both where
a way to classically get to know each
other is to go for a drink and I don't
think it's quite as automatic as it
would be for someone from the United
States or someone from Canada of course
they do it but there's just something
innate when you meet someone for the
first time you like fancy drink it just
happens it says it's as much as saying
hello or shaking someone's hand you just
go do a quick drink in America yeah you
don't you don't just go up to people
like you meet a guy and go hey you seem
really happy why don't we go get a beer
yeah it might seem a little bit
presumptuous well maybe you're like
alright maybe he thinks that I'm gay
right but of course like not that
there's anything wrong with there's no
obvious Lee there's nothing wrong with
it but it maybe that's the perception
maybe in in North America
yeah that people if you just meet a guy
for the first time like you're really
kind you've got a great smile I heard
about your measurements we should go
have a frosty right that's what I and
the souks are the something in Los
Angeles as well I feel that when
somebody goes for a drink they have to
go for the greatest drink ever made they
have to see I know a place in the valley
that does a martini that we have to go
to and you're like that's a 40 minute
drive and there's a bar right there I
can see it with my eyes that serves beer
yeah beer and I'm sure a martini but now
we have to go in this place that just
open so that we can stand in line to get
this martini that's made with chocolate
from Peru
and that chili left them it's like it's
like Billy's totally right in telling
that story I was going through make up
and I think lies you insured males
possibly had more to do that day because
our rehearsal process was quite kind of
rich in terms of dialect training sword
fine horse right you really rehearse
these scenes it wasn't like you had like
oh let's go through it once or twice
it's like you are like you know these
scenes inside out before you're filming
and we're there with Pete Pete Jackson
is the the king of that whole project so
if you're sat in a rehearsal room with
pee and with Fran and Philippa who were
his co writers and co-producers you're
not just pissing about like you you
having to bring stuff and bring
questions and you know you're really
getting into a popularly alongside horse
riding sword fighting kayaking all that
kind of stuff
and I think in my memory Shaun and
Elijah might have a might have had more
stuff to do and Billy wrapped for the
day the same time as me and we were both
heading into town we're just like let's
get a drink and what was amazing about
that was it immediately cemented what
became one of the more formats of things
that Billy and I did witness which was a
a little bit of drinking and be playing
pool because we played pool up and down
the length and breadth of those Islands
we were prey good it was better be
honest yeah there are 10 games to play
who would win set you were better at a
time maybe even now yeah I would say
Billy would probably win he's saying ten
I would say Billy would win seven and
how it went through who would be drunk
more drunk maybe younger maybe he beat
you
yeah he's always been more responsible
than me although you did have a few
moments of being a tearaway oh
absolutely I think with pool I think I
think there's this weird thing with pool
where if you get just the right amount
of alcohol in you you game improves
because it's a game of confidence and
poise and a little bit of cockiness but
one extra than there your game starts to
follow you remember a bar we were in I
think we were on location I think in
this so thaelin somewhere
excuse me I know not all and he and we
we went on the pool table and but you
know where was that it was ignorance
time it was Queens and I I think it was
called the snake pit so the Queen's tone
is known as the sort of adrenaline
capital of New Zealanders where you
bungee jump and you know tribes
adventure adventure so everyone there is
like you know young guys from America
and Australian you know it's all these
guys with North Face t-shirts in
Patagonia ha yeah this is hot oh sorry
that's Empire Strikes Back thank you go
ahead we're in this bar and we start
beatin people and it's winner stays on
doubles so we're just beating all these
guys coming from everywhere we're on the
table for like three hours just beaten
everyone was crazy til the guy behind
the bar calls up the champion pool
players from Queenstown and gets them to
come to the bar to beat us and it'd be
you know what we beat the champions of
New Zealand and my mind probably
Queenstown at least but the guy behind
the bar calls up the people to come and
get us off the table
we were we were in this like van at 6:00
that's cool yeah I wrote in my diary why
you're such you know brothers and we
were in this like weird flow like I
don't the the rest of the day is kind of
vague but I'm gonna assume we went out
had a couple of beers had some food and
then we were playing casual pool someone
came over to kind of get the table
offers and we were like well play winner
stays on because we want it to keep
playing so we thought well if we beat
these guys then Billy and I can keep
playing our game of singles so we beat
those people
someone put coins on the table or now we
gotta play these people and it became a
thing feels good where we were looking
at you Oh Mike we play everyone we
played - we play did you get laid that
night down maybe you did I mean it
wasn't just women there were pigeons
that were sat on the windowsill looking
in did you go yesterday and brag about
it yeah yeah
and they wouldn't believe a freaking
look of it I mean this is 20 years ago
we're still bragging about yeah this is
this is irrelevant but it's an elephant
irrelevant I want you to tell me what
this is I this is by accident I found
this can I say how much higher is your
voice but then hey hey like coming over
I knew what was going on did you hear
the other voice is that me no the
narrator was it you it was me you've got
great voice but there you can see it was
higher because we were both younger they
said hey they want you to be there was
during when I was on small they just
said you want to be the narrator for the
two towers for the for the TV special
and I go hell yeah we'll give you for
Lord of the Rings tickets will fly you
in first class we'll pay you some money
like what what you mean who's a friend
you mean low doing States to the
premiere to the premiere sorry yeah yeah
yeah well a in Hollywood yeah Wow our
client yeah wherever it was I was there
can I tell you a funny story that would
have been hilarious have we done it and
I really wanted to do it but Billy and
Elijah and I think Orlando nixed it and
I was like oh come on we got to do it so
I you you you'll remember this at the
ArcLight if you approach the ArcLight
from Sunset Boulevard so you've walked
past amoeba repping out on your right
you cross the street
yeah then there's the way to go in just
don't on the side there there's a little
water feature that has like gently
flowing water yeah I know usually in the
summertime falling on to some like soft
pebbles I would call them yes great for
skimming rose type of pebbles right so
when we do in the premiere for two
towers it must have been I said to Billy
Elijah in Orlando let's stand underneath
the water feature
all of us get completely soaking wet and
do the red carpet and not mention it at
all like when people say you clearly
soaking wet don't say anything just do
the if you didn't do it no and I was
like come on let's go was with you not
only anyone's nobody was with you now
had you had a few beers yeah maybe
no Dom always heard yes you're a Viking
was it your idea to get the tattoo of
the nine now that was probably more
orally but I was one of the ringleader
one yeah we all have a tattoo on your
right arm
no anywhere anywhere you wanted it so
where's yours Billy on my right ankle on
your right ankle and it's the Elven
number nine number nine because there's
nine of us nine of you yeah and we all
went all eight of us seven of us because
Sean Bean was already dead
mr. Baine not in real life what Sean
Blaine he always very good at it right
so he was already gone and John
rhys-davies didn't want a tattoo okay
hey why not why not
is it I'm not sure but yeah I saw was he
was he let me guess was he a he just he
was Jewish and he couldn't be tattoo
because they can't bury a Jew or who's
religious and whatnot
okay was he was he a really delicate
skin that would maybe just blow
profusely he was deathly allergic to his
Gimli makeup so he couldn't wear it for
two days in a row okay
well or was he an [ __ ] no I think
John was because he's quite a lot older
than us Johnny was the oldest member of
the fellowship and I do think that John
probably thought that tattoos were more
in the groups of sailors drug dealers
and bikers you didn't have it he didn't
have a tattoo it wasn't because this is
- this is the year 2000 is it yeah yeah
and I still remember back then thinking
oh I'm one of the minority that has a
tattoo but now we're at the very least
even steven how many do you have Billy I
just have that one you have that one
tattoo so is it hard to convince Billy
to do this no Billy was definitely easy
the only ones that were even slight
a challenge I think Ian McKellan had to
slightly yeah sort into it but he was
good with it when we approached him he
was like hmm okay don't think about it
and then once everyone was doing it he's
fine were you there when he got it we
were all that how did anyone weep or was
in pit they couldn't handle it as much I
got a tattoo with my brother we wrote my
grandmother's name who passed and he was
just a puss
I mean loved him but he was just like oh
I'm like are you kidding me right this
is a joking yeah I doesn't might hurt
that bad I didn't think it hurt that bad
I remember Sean Astin being the one who
moaned give me a Sean Astin moan just
did he get his foot on us same place as
me yeah just like I saw so and he was
before us all and I thought oh he's
quite so but I think on your foot is
it's quite it's been oh you know who was
the he was the coolest about it no pain
there you go he got was cool Vigo
already had a bunch attack God he's so
beautiful he's like and then he hasn't a
pain every threshold honestly here's my
favorite vegan
how cool is Viggo store when he made out
with you no that's not cool that was we
wouldn't tell that story we will but we
wrote one nay that became an a of
drinking and and just just a great night
you know everybody went oh I think it
was snowing it was a crazy night were on
vodka and there wasn't many of those
nights you know because we worked so
hard and they started at 4:00 a.m. so
there wasn't a lot of Begg nights out
but this one was great and everyone was
there and it got to like 3:00 in the
morning we weren't working the next day
the next day was a travel day gets till
like 3:00 in the morning gets to bed
crash we had to get up at say about 8:00
or 9:00 to travel to the next place and
ICV go downstairs getting into you know
the car that's gonna drive well I'm
getting a car that's driving me and I
see he's holding something like a big
square like was that Viggo was that you
got I was like it's great Nate last
night yeah greenie I was there was that
it pills it up it's a painting that he
did when he got end that night like an
amazing painting like you know he stayed
up all night even deeper 4 foot by 4
foot something like that when everybody
else is smashed and asleep and he's
probably a little smashed - yeah totally
and he's and he's making art he's making
art that I could never imagine a just
you know what I imagined him naked for
some reason doing this oh he was I'm
sure when he was writing poetry and it
was in the back of a pony yeah he's
brilliant Vigo he's like the greatest
example in my life up to now of the
quintessential artist I mean obviously
Billy's an amazing artist he's an actor
he's a oh he's a saying Gary's a
songwriter I look at the things that he
does with music and I think wow that's
that's incredible and Vigo's not quite
an accomplished musician as Billy but in
terms of the way that Billy viga looks
at his life everything is an opportunity
to be artistic whether it's writing or
drawing it's a brilliant poet it's a
brilliant photographer and I mean
obviously as an actor I mean the journey
that Vigo has gone on from I think after
Eragon he was offered pretty much
everything that any lead man was offered
turned it down turned it down turn it
down he wanted to do stuff with horses I
did a couple of films and horses spent a
lot of time with his family how do you
how do you do that that's it you know at
a different level how do you have it I
mean how do I he does so much and when
do you spread yourself too thin like for
him it seems like he doesn't he just
does what he wants and he enjoys it and
I think the key maybe is to do something
and not try to be you're not trying to
be great at it you're not trying to make
money at it you're just trying to enjoy
it yeah and I'd like to think that's
what I'm trying to do is I go into this
next chapter of my life for I'm just
like you don't have to be great at
everything yeah good at everything
stop being so hard and so just Billy you
play music it makes you feel good right
you love it if you make no money you're
still gonna play music exactly an exit I
think you've you've hit the nail on the
head oh that's haven't fun phrase listen
I'm gonna write that down
hit the nail
on the head well done Billy you haven't
skimmed off the side there you've got it
right in the center it's a boat just
making something and getting out there
and just enjoying it every I think too
many people worry that oh it's not quite
ready it's not it's not quite polished
and office no not gonna lie it's not
good enough people wouldn't like I'll be
embarrassed yeah where is you get more
attracted to art that's a bit twisted
and broken you know I mean also like the
cosmos that the older that I've got the
more I've felt like this there's some
sort of there's some sort of personality
which is it which is not the greatest
way of describing the cosmos this
there's some sort of presence and Jesus
Mike who you want calm down a little
that's my Cameron expensives I like it
oh no it's an Olympus or it's a piece of
[ __ ] I think that there's something very
significant to be said for holding on
too tight to something when you really
want something yeah he trying super hard
it's like sand like slipping through
your fingertips he just he's squeezing
too tight and it just falls through the
thing that Viggo does certainly has an
example being a young man that I've
watched and as I've grown older and
become closer and closer to Viggo is he
lives in flow right he just flows in
flow comes back to LA I'm here for a few
days any time you go over to Vigo's
house there's always a rat not a rabble
but a bunch people there and he's very
present I take it very present but like
some of his family's there some of his
friends there he's got a fire lit he's
made some food he's cooking up some star
you vegetarian that's okay I got some
stuff in my fridge there's no hassles
I've never seen Vigo be like oh I forgot
the thing I'm gonna do this he just
didn't flow he's never late how do you
how do you that's a good question for
you guys a couple serious things or
important things things that you know
when people take out they're like these
guys are really funny and all this but
how do you turn off
how do you stay present and how do you
separate your work where you're not your
work I've talked to many different
people about this but what's your theory
like what do you do to not obsess on all
I've got wild things I've got this other
movie I've got my you know my music I've
got my family I'm gay
how do you turn off and just be present
what is it it's something that you've
always been able to do or you were
taught or you were yeah I think it's
incredibly important I think it's the
most important thing and life is being
in a place where you are being present
you know and I know there's a sort of M
buzz world and all that and a way of
thinking but I think it's a universal
truth and has been for thousands of
years and people understand that's the
way to be successful as a human I
actually putting that into practice as
really difficult but I think once you
understand that that is the most
important thing then you you know try
and you know Bend your life a little bit
to try and make that as simple as you
can and if that's meditating which as
for a lot of people and or if it's just
changing the way you think of things or
you know some people will give you a
really good two second meditation where
you just remember and just go just
breathe then breathe I just wanna lay to
give to my son which is you know when it
all gets too hectic I'm supposed to do
this but I'm supposed to be there and I
haven't learnt this you know what just
breathe then breathe out and say to
yourself I'm breathing in and breathing
out and it just kind of brings you back
to where you where you are where you
should be you know do you deal with any
kind of like I mean you've had like if
you look at the story of your life and I
don't know you that well obviously at a
young age you had some you went through
some [ __ ] as a kid you know your grandma
raised you you lost your parents at a
young age you know some people could sit
there and say my parents were
dysfunctional and this and that but are
you someone who dwells in the past I'm
gonna look who still has moments where
you go back and go what the you know do
you feel like you've still got one foot
in the past or do you try to really be
present and move forward and and and you
haven't needed to talk about it and deal
with it or have you already dealt with
it do you know what there's
it's really complicated I think and I
suppose it depends Anna tame that you
live in the world and that the moment
nothing against you from earlier on when
you said you blamed your parents because
you were too sure there's a big thing
just no it's good to blame your parents
for everything you know I feel and in
some ways this is an awful thing you see
I'm sure in some ways because I lost my
parents when I was young it freed me
from that because I couldn't blame them
because they weren't there so I had my
one thing to deal with and so I couldn't
see you should've made me go soccer more
I would have been a great soccer player
if you had you know pushed me a little I
didn't have that so I had to save myself
I should have played soccer more you
know I was my fault you know so in an
awful way it was freeing because in the
world that we live in where I think
people like to blame the parents for
everything
I didn't have that I was left with
myself you know I couldn't blame my
grandmother she was slowly getting
smaller and smaller but you know and and
everyone has their baggage you know so I
grew up in a council estate in Scotland
so I have that Scottish or I'm Scottish
impressed something about that that you
know I think nationalism isn't a great
thing I think it's lovely it's a I'm
Scott you should look at our great
history but don't be nationalists about
it you know I think that causes a lot of
problems in the world you know that my
country is better than yours so I kind
of watch that and then working-class is
another one that's a real sort of chip
on my shoulder that we've got a fate you
know what Marxist we've got to kind of
you know defeat these and you you know
you put yourself in these groups and I
think these groups that you put yourself
and causes a lot of problems in your
life so the more you can kind of just
try and get rid of those groups and just
kind of go hey I'm
in this room with these three guys and
great guys this is fun we're talking
were lessening the more that the world
can do that just know I think the better
boy when you just Zone in and you're not
we're not goofing around I was just like
it's beautiful captivating I know it
sounds funny but I feel like I just
learned something it is in a
three-minute thing you just said I feel
like I'm listening and I'm going you
know you didn't have your parents to
blame but in a sense and I'm like and I
don't necessarily play my parents I let
things go and I love them but I in a
sense I'm lucky that I had that yeah so
always be grateful always just be
grateful for whatever you had because
someone had it worse and this is life
and it's only gonna get worse or better
at times intermittently yeah and like
but it just nothing just things into
perspective yeah
perspective is huge right yeah but it's
also another easy thing to see and a
difficult thing to do because we need to
when you look in perspective you just
think that guy's got big hosts he's
getting three cars and so you have to
[Laughter]
you know yeah to speak to speak on
Billy's behalf if I could for a minute
thank you that she knew his beautiful
know something I think Billy had to do
quite a lot of growing up a little
faster than most people needed to when I
was Billy's age when he sadly lost his
parents I was still running around at
school and doing plays and having fun
and eating lollipops and all that kind
of stuff so really had to grow up a lot
quicker than certainly I did and I think
because of that Billy worked out things
that I worked out a little later of like
it's all right everything's fine like
get happy do the things that make her
smile
be grateful so I've watched Billy I mean
Billy's a little bit older than me but
in terms of his I don't look at tiny I
mean I bet you know he doesn't say he
looks young he does the Peter Pan what
he was the Peter Pan of the hub
I mean Elijah looks amazingly young sean
astin looks young yeah I look young but
everyone would go on about Billy's age
go yeah you are joking you're 64 you
look incredible 65 but he's Billy just
got there a little quicker so Billy and
I are obviously friends and peers and
we've helped each other out over the
years but there's been times where I've
been struggling with something and Billy
got there 810 years ago so there was a
time we were walking down a bikini one
time I was seeing a girl I was kind of
half in half out I was like yeah I like
about not sure and I turn around to
Billy we were leaving at this point he
was going back to his wife and son I was
walking to my car I said Billy shouting
at him across that bikini which was
completely inappropriate
Billy howdy how are you okay with the
fact that you know it's just you and
Allie now for the rest of your life
instead of like other girls to kiss or
other girls to look at and Billy said be
here now right be here now like this is
my situation now I love it I'm here now
he was yelling that across the street
like 15 feet away you know and I got an
account of a found and simple yeah
totally be here now dude [ __ ] off what
are you gonna do you know like kiss
think about that when it comes when it
happens if someone punch me right in the
throat you know that's a beautiful
moment and I he's been able to do that
for me over the years listen I want to
get to this because I got something
really cool that you know coming up this
is awesome to hear these stories and you
know wish we had more time maybe you
guys will come back I seriously yeah
well yeah yeah no it's really okay yeah
I've enjoyed it yeah I have to I think
you're really fun oh thanks man
I new dome was fun thank you I don't get
no idea who that guy Ryan I'm sorry
that's right no I just but Ryan's
amazing and he's funny actually don't
put him on the spot to be funny Ryan you
know these hello Ryan come on you've
seen the Lord of the Rings right yeah of
course oh my god yeah do you know a lot
about it did you read the books I did
not read the books though No
get out right you should all right
they're good books yeah are they I don't
know there's a lot of books in this room
yeah a lot of the Rings and here I'm not
a big reader I don't think people look
at me and like oh he's an intellectual
but I do like history so I read you know
the John Adams book
read I read let's not bore people well
okay John Adams is that the summer of 69
you know that's Brian John's was second
President of the United States it's also
a lawyer who defended the British you
you just said don't be sorry all right
now there's so much I want to talk to
you about but I want to get into
something that's important so really
quick make these quick you were in the
room you were at the bar when a girl
smack tom full handed on the face
correct you were there i learned more
than once so the this girl just woman
came up to you and you didn't do
anything wrong right no for my
recollection mean Billy might be able to
tell a different story from my
recollection we're in Thailand we had
walked through a bar onto the beach
where there were beach tables associated
with the bar and we were having member
this now yeah we were just having it
really it was just nice conversation
lovely but conversation we had a couple
of beers we were getting into something
kind of fun I was into it with my best
mate in Thailand we really under good
time and this girl drunk came over and
just said can I sit here and I kind of
said yeah you can sit there but I was in
no way interested in starting a
conversation right right we ignored her
for a good thirty seconds and then she
said something along the lines of am i
boring you or shouldn't I be here and I
said something like yeah kind of like
like I'm talking to my mate and the next
thing I knew she smacked me in the face
it hurt did it hurt yeah guys move over
get up Jonny States we stayed still in
Chile did you laugh did you I know it
looked painful
it wasn't a laughing slap it was like Oh
mark on your face I had tears in my eyes
not because I was upset because it hurts
the worst here ah yeah and nothing
happened she just got up walked away
let's continue the conversation yeah
which i think is the right way to deal
with it right she had so little effect
on me that after she hit me I just
continued to ignore it I would it seems
like I would have done something like
this let's say I was talking to Billy
and also I got his Mac to go oh my gosh
why would you do that yeah dude I could
you believe it happened then we can put
yourself in the moment there I magical
act out the [ __ ] what do I do I'm
talking to my friend yeah it's good I
think I sell all those things but when I
say it now I connect emotional
connected with bill as soon as it
happened and Billy looked at me with
this face which I know that Billy gives
often which is like that just happened
it kind of went and do it also cuz you
like you're you're a tough guy Dom like
you I don't know like these people look
at you and you think they don't know
that you'd be tough if they don't know
you you wouldn't go on a bar and go oh I
wouldn't fight that guy but you're kind
of the guy that's like if you [ __ ] mess
with me I'm you know I'm not afraid of
you a little bit played around with fear
a lot in my life so I think I definitely
have that I don't know about a bar
situation I mean if the bigger guys
mister sure you're not stupid I'm gonna
leave right but I'm not I'm I'm this is
one of the fundamental differences I
think between Billy and I and I've
learned a lot through watching bill is I
get off on and I'm energized by
confrontation and Billy over the years I
don't like I pretended to be like that's
not my jam and Dom well he if he scared
the some as if there's fear he'll look
into that and and yeah I don't like fear
know I could sue me yeah he said to me
last last year as a peg is a big Shark
Week thing happening and the VAS does
mean Tom do we want to go and swim with
great waves and I was like no and he's
like but why wouldn't you I mean this is
a chance and I was like I don't yeah
I don't want his swim I've seen jaws I
mean you know I mean and I can't get
Dom's when Tom's like I was like will we
be in a cage no we'll just be swimming
that's crazy Dom what if one hears what
goes on I take it not only my mom but
Billy's mine and probably the rest of
the world what if one of them is hungry
yeah what if one of us taken what I have
a feeling that they're on the one person
they won't like yeah they'll look at me
and go oh that's not a regular human I
want to eat his dumb ass yeah man well
if you're exhibiting a lot of fear in
the water you might you might get
wouldn't you well okay so forgive me but
you guys are both coming from less of a
place of knowledge about sharks than I
am not that I'm an expert on sharks but
I know a little bit more about sharks
than you I I know when a shark bites his
eyes are all over
scared lifeless eyes dolls eyes sorry so
no it's alright but the monstrous myth
that has been built about shark and
other animals is something that is paint
li not true we there are an average of
eight shark attacks a year on humans and
how many karakov which may be two of
them a fail and we kill 1,700 sharks a
second are you serious
as second so that's hundreds of millions
of sharks are dying a year and they maim
us eight to ten so you're saying we
deserve her I'm saying this this is just
statistical but the statistics of it but
if we were to go swimming with sharks
which we were gonna do but it didn't
happen
there are there are different times of
the year where sharks are in feeding
mode so you we would I would not get in
the water with great whites when they
are laundry or low on body fat ready to
feed looking for seals looking for
anything what we would do is we would go
swimming them when you've got heavily
pregnant females they literally turn off
their digestive system they turn off
their aggression so you can you can hang
on to their dorsal fin swim around with
them and they're just not interested
they don't have an appetite they're not
interested so not only that but being on
a boat with Billy and exploring the idea
of fear and then getting someone like
Billy who might have a little bit more
fear into the water is so empowering to
people who are terrified of sharks cuz
they look at million go he seemed a
little scared of sharks Wow and now he's
swimming with a great white maybe I can
do that too
it sets you free what if what if what if
your your theory or your your experiment
went wrong would you then say you guys
were all right or would you try to get
John asked in there then go swimming if
something went terribly wrong of course
you have to deal with those consequences
I'm always playing certainly with
animals with statistics I guess so it
looks dangerous but from my knowledge
and from the way that we're working them
is statistically way less dangerous than
it looks
and you know it just in my mind it just
wouldn't happen obviously like Billy
said what if you got angry turned around
didn't like the look of you right there
huge chunk of you you're injured you're
in trouble did you almost get in a fight
with Orlando Bloom once yeah I almost
got into like a but it would probably I
think I mean hopefully Billy would
display up cuz
you were there hilly I was there I was
just remembering it and my mind and you
know the main thing that I remember from
that one was Dom's shoes were you
wearing adidas tom homework we're
freshers was wearing
there were like brown ox blood sort of
shoes almost like a Cuban heel that had
had a kind of they had REM random like
that you know I don't know whether at
all or steel no just like leather but
you know and it was stitched in and I
remember I remember you kept Orlando
Bloom and the time I thought well I bet
that really hot yeah bet it hurt but you
kicked him yeah I kicked him so not on
purpose no not on purpose we we were in
a bar we've gone to Sydney myself oli
large and bill and I think Elijah like
had an early night or some things of the
three or maybe he went home early after
dinner and we had been training the week
before in New Zealand and I had
destroyed my tricep muscles the most
sort my muscles have ever been in my
entire life I couldn't touch him I
couldn't like extend my arm you know
that feeling in the gym well you're so
sore I know what happened now I could
feel had to know I had to sleep on my
back and I said to the guys on the plane
I was like guys because we all train
with this guy Dave nuku I said my arms
are destroyed please just don't be
conscious of that and they're like yeah
okay fine
Ollie for the rest of the week would
just come behind me and just pinch my
triceps just a game I had and it was
excruciating
ahh I really heard only don't go
seriously don't don't don't anybody that
I'm sorry mate I'm sorry you knew
exactly what was doing this happened
over the course of at least a day if not
to so you let it go I let it go I let it
go I told him I was like don't do that
so cuz he knew and then we're in a bar
we were drinking he came up behind me he
grabbed both my triceps and SQUOZE him
and I just I just lost it so I just I
just horse kicked him I'd wear um
probably around his thigh or net hurt
him yeah yeah he was he was upset so
then he got in my face and I got in his
face and I was like I've been telling
you I've been telling you that I'm gonna
fight back if you keep doing it and he's
all you know
Wiggy and stuff and abilities try to
stop it no Bailey we stood right next
who's thinking I'm gonna see this one
out now you're being interesting now I
think you've got really bad yeah hug it
out eventually did but it got heated it
got heat like nose-to-nose yeah yeah
like [ __ ] you yeah pushing you yeah yeah
yeah all that still didn't anybody say
look I don't want to fight you right now
but I told you a million times if you
want to [ __ ] throw down I'm gonna
throw down with you no I don't think was
I don't wanna fight I think it was a lot
of light
you know I've told you what the [ __ ] is
your problem I told you and it got
pretty heavy and then I think bill at
some point was like alright come on guys
let's have a drink and when we went to
get a drink
then it turned into quite sweetly the
two of us being a bit upset where I was
like me why would you do that and I got
upset and he was like I forgot and I was
like you couldn't have forgot it's been
going on say so but he never did it
again that's the thing he didn't do you
know what it happened to me I was bald
it was a second year Smallville one of
my friends was in Vancouver with me and
we were walking around my other two
friends and he kind of smacked me in the
back of the head on a cold frosty vent
day and I go I hate it I'll do that man
come on and then he did it again and I
go dude stop that man it actually really
hurts man
don't do that and they did it again and
then he did it again and the fourth time
I go he's a big dude I go listen man Jay
you're a big [ __ ] dude and I know
you'll probably beat the [ __ ] out of me
if you do that one more time I'm gonna
punch you in your [ __ ] face and
you're gonna bleed do you understand one
more time and that [ __ ] didn't do it
get because I think he realized I'm
going to [ __ ] hit you yeah and I
think Orlando pushed you over that more
like he thought you were maybe kidding
whatever it was funny and you let him
know it's not yeah yeah sometimes people
do yeah you learn things about people in
those places as well I think it's it was
quite a formative bonding moment sure we
know where we realize okay we have lines
one of us crossed the lines we've talked
about it and now we're but can I ask you
something about your bald head yeah so
when you played Lex Luthor I was born
wasn't a bald cap when you played Lex
Luthor for how many seasons six of them
seven the entire time he's bald yeah so
you shaved your head for seven million
episode every Oh every episode they do
hours cuz they had to put all this
makeup but my fan my listeners have
heard a million times but it took two
hours for the first three years because
they had to put all these different
colors and because I can't have a hair
line and it was it was a lot did you
notice a difference in the way that
people kind of came to you in the street
because now you've got an intense kind
of look yeah it was weird
in fact it helped me with the role it
really did once I shaved my head I go I
could do this I go I could do this now
it was like when I had hair I didn't
know if I thought they'd fire me and
then the second they shaved it in the
trailer and I looked in the mirror I go
and I put that suit on you look cool
heavy came I didn't came Lex Luthor you
know is it and I get the confidence just
exude have been really your best
thinking that show oh thank you Yemen
you are bill you've never seen him I'm
not gonna say because I like Kristen oh
yeah yeah she's amazing
she's a very good love her she was on
the podcast she's fair I love that I
really love them all really yeah so she
must love you she wouldn't do another
know everybody's enough all right listen
I want to get into this because you have
to go and do it if it really wasn't late
we would have had more time you like
that a little bit I feel like I could do
that I feel like we're but we have a
bonding I don't think no we're not we're
not building my social group as the
loveliest man in the world this is
outside of I heard this stuff all my
mankini and friends are like how's the
loveliest man in the world and I'll go
I'm fine and they go no no not you Billy
and I go oh he's fine well he is he
sweet you're sweet to your you know I
like I said I don't believe that but
you'll send me text just send me little
emails your present your like you like I
could tell like I want to hang out with
you more and we don't but it's like
there's still that bonding we're like
when we do hang out it's easy it's just
easy and that so that's a Dolan Cana
cares you know it keeps he keeps it
doesn't like forget about people you
know he's and I like that there's not
many people like that alright let me get
into this you have talked for a while it
sounded to me like Dom you've been
talking to Billy and Billy's finally on
board you guys have worked some stuff
out and there's a strong possibility of
you doing a podcast together mmm I'm
really into it now
at first it sounded like a great weight
situation
and I don't want to jump in the war but
I'm and I'm a hundred person I think
this is exciting because I mean you see
another podcast and I have a feeling
well I know it's it's it's going to be
Lord of the Rings oriented well yeah
that'll be the foundation I would think
um why don't you talk about because
we're gonna do the first episode after
this why don't you talk yeah you're
gonna record it here in my house yeah
we've warmed up we're ready it's a good
thing you really yeah yeah so it will be
that will definitely come back to loader
rings because that was an intense four
years where we first met and we have you
know many stories never been told I'm
sure and there so I'm sure as we talk as
Dom says you know there were formative
in our relationship and things that we
still think no so I know that we'll
always come back to Lord of the Rings in
our time in New Zealand but we'll also
look at other things we'll we'll go deep
and if some things as we did today I
feel like it will it will then it will
find its own shape do you think do you
have a name already have you discussed
name well we might talk about that on
the podcast but like the the working
tile at the moment
go on dom the working title at the
moment which I don't think will stick so
we might think something else is to hubs
in a pod to harvest in a podcast
yeah that was not my idea that came from
my dear dear friend Nigel who we made
during loader um I said to Billy
probably a year ago now or something
like around about that time I said we
should do a podcast and it took a little
while because when I first did that
Billy was like great what time's it on
and I was like no we have to record it
and he's like what what stations are on
no it's not on a station I thought my
dad yeah podcast listened to I was like
you you go into your podcast app on your
phone is that I don't listen to podcast
I was like well you should start listen
to some and use that I don't understand
when would I listen to it in the house
I'm not going to it cuz I'm doing other
stuff than else I was like when you
drive in he's not know when I'm driving
and listen to music so I was like
we both a conversationalist we both have
stories to tell if we sit next to each
other we become chatterboxes and I said
it'll be great and in the last I would
say probably two or three months
Billy's be much more along the lines of
like yeah let's do this this is actually
going to be two hobbits and a part or
two Hobbs in a part
Hubbs in a part is Canada working two to
Hobbs in a part I kind it's kind of
catchy yeah so does that mean that we
steal all your listeners they all come
oh I hope so I hope you know I don't
like Stewart Steele how about if they
like it they'll go visit and I'll go
well first of all they're gonna love you
guys they love Dom when he came on last
he likes
if you guys are gonna talk about things
that are interesting and talk about your
lives and what I like about today is
that your relationship it's just it's
dynamic and the way you bounce off each
other you should have a podcast and it's
gonna be fun and I'm watching you guys
go at it now and laugh and enjoy each
other and I think that's 90% of it well
you come on ears then why why will you
come on to airport how did I sound
points to her war for sure absolutely
but just to be thankful to you for a
moment Rosie because you're kind of my
podcast mentor you've created a very
successful podcast I'm still working on
it it's an old girl found it it's still
very successful and you've you've said
to me over the years well if you do it
it would happen like this and this is a
way to do this is a way to monetize it
this is a way to gain fans this is a way
to think about how it works so I do
appreciate that because as Billy and I
are moving towards doing this this
podcast after this it's been based on a
lot of the advice where you have said I
would do it like this and think about
that and stuff so I'm learning to by the
way accept compliments and I'm going to
say thank you very much and I sincerely
mean that I'm being present nice I like
that I really am look I think a lot of
talented people or people were
successful hanging around with people
that are very smart and know what
they're doing and they ask advice you
know I used to be watched so I'm just
gonna do things but when you ask people
that really know how to do things so I
have people that are helping me along
and I'm always looking for ways to
expand you know grow my audience and
but you know I have a meeting after this
there's so many ways to do it and it
takes time it takes dedication and you
have to stick with it and it's
consistency and it's something for me I
just found purpose in this podcast I
found like when I put these on I could
actually listen to people I actually I
just know I feel present I feel like I
want to talk to you I feel like I can't
escape I can't I mean I could but I
don't want to get up and go watch TV or
read something or play up my I wanna sit
here and talk to people that I play with
you know dog like actual dogs make sure
you dogs the main thing that brought me
on is I have always thought since
meeting Don and that's 20 years now
there's something comic that we can do
together something funny that we haven't
done yet and whether that's a movie or a
TV show or we write a script or whatever
is I think there's an original comedy
voice that I think we have missed and I
think you know I think the podcast might
find that and I think that's the thing
that me is most interesting to me you
know whether as the podcast or it
becomes something I don't know but I do
think we we have lost some and there's
been people along the way good producers
as you see smart people who have tried
to make it happen and for whatever
reason it hasn't and I think there's
something there you know and it would be
shame if one of us died before it came
I'm not sure where this thing will go
either but in my mind I've always I'm a
big fan of like visualization or a lot
kind of stuff and I've always seen
myself with Billy doing this podcast at
a convention with the energy of an
audience and realize that's what I want
to do that - yes I want to get into that
- I go the cons and start doing these
things right but I'm up like hey ha
there's a guest I like to interview them
what because that that's what I want to
start so instead of doing a one-hour Q&A
you do a one-hour pod because that
energy in the audience everyone if I
anything that I post on
Instagram people like if I post Billy it
gets five to six times more followers
and likes than I would do just posted me
because ever wants to see myself and
Billy or merry and pippin together same
here so we can be in a room it's like
you and I'm welling it's absolute time
they see you they're like oh my god my
childhood oh we we do these things
called Smallville Knights I came up this
idea and I pitched it to Tom he goes I
like it I go listen here's why because
Tom's private in a sense he's like Billy
that you know it's like I go what if we
do these things these intimate little
nights these improvisational nights
called Smallville nights at these cons
on one night
they're not allowed to bring cameras
there's no video there's no recording
it's just a moment with us and the fans
and we reenact [ __ ] there's something we
have so much fun I bring a bald cap I
like and he's very and Tom it's just so
funny and so open cuz he's comfortable
and usually a private person we've done
three of them and they're a menace ly
successful they people really and by the
way I didn't want to do something where
I'm like I'm not just I don't take
someone's money I want them to be
entertained what they were like that was
worth every cent
I spent I want them to walk out going
that way it prizes we give Smallville
stuff away we we do things we'd never do
yeah and it's a beautiful thing
so you know sometimes I think we look at
things like our past and we go you know
I don't want people to know I was Lex
Luthor but let's talk about the present
that's it was a huge thing yeah why it's
like why not go from Lord of the Rings
you know I mean and maybe go a Star Wars
Star Wars question but you're in Star
Wars you can't I know I mean a pop and
being in it yeah I can let me just ask
you this you can't even say if you're in
more than only scene huh I'm in more
than once my characters called blink and
you'll miss me that's the name of the
cat is it I play one of those in gardens
galaxy 2 so he's just like that that's
why I keep telling everyone is if you
tell people oh blink and you'll miss me
then they think he's gonna song I want
to be ready why can you miss me I love
it loves me I'm the little guy blink can
you miss me I've got a tear in my eye
think think can you miss me and now I'm
gone listen
to the new podcast when it's all little
did I love this this is brilliant I wish
you guys the best I'm Johnny
Thank You Billy for Lamba inside you
yeah what a treat so I'm gonna allow you
guys to stay in this room with Ryan and
now you're gonna record it's kind of
it's cool it's like George Lucas writing
Star Wars yeah I think we should switch
seats
I should probably sit where you oh you
sit well yeah some of us sit here you
sit there I'm quite comfortable guys
thanks for listening I hope that I was
as enjoyable for you as it was Ryan and
I we we love those guys they were a lot
of fun to listen to
they have so many stories and so many
more stories to come as you could only
imagine just so make sure you whatever
they do you follow you listen you spread
the word for them and big shout out to
my top peer patrons newbies Scott B
Thank You Raj C we got Chris Jason D
mark aka crutch
Alison Elle and Kristin K I wonder if
Kristin K is Kristin Kreuk no oh hey I
can't say the last things you're mad but
it's Kristin K the oh geez here on
patron thank you Jason WD on K board X
Robert B Bobby Emily
Kevin R Jerry W my grandma's Catan
here's my grandma Blanche hey I'm doing
my podcast right now could I call you a
little later are you doing all right
yeah have you want any money playing
Marjan or anything
two dollars what are you gonna do with
it I don't know I'm trying to figure it
out yeah I love you did you get anything
from me I did I got gorgeous flowers
you're gonna go broke sending me flowers
well I'm gonna be broken happy because I
love you and I want to give you some
flowers
well you make me very happy
you so much all right you're the best
I'll talk to you a little later okay
darling bye I love that woman
that was an interesting guest a little
visit from Blanche oh my grandpa yeah
you should man I love her
where was I thank you to Barry L Nico P
Lauren g MH Jill E Yukiko I love my
Yukiko Sarah V Tricia Lee s Nancy T
Nancy D it just sounds provocative
doesn't it let's new Kobe Nancy Drew it
could be a Nancy Drew or just Nancy
Nancy day honestly without you guys I
mean your support on patreon is huge and
it helps pay for guys like Ryan and me
and Brice and all the costs of cameras
and things like that it just it really
helps in your subscription is not
overlooked and it is it's honestly
awesome and continue to help me spread
the word about the show and let's grow
it together remembering to be in
Richmond in Mexico coming up why don't
we play a song from left on Laurel why
not let's play this is little boy from
left on Laurel it's still us from the
album for free all right guys thank you
so much thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
especially in CD Jesus all right guys I
love you thank you for listening and
thanks for the support
[Music]
well I was thinking
times we had
and what a shame it was
Oh
trying to make me come home
seeing things a little different
but you never open your eyes see just
you feel like a child
pigging out in the backseat